le conseil d'état dont on estime les
origines au moyen-âge à deux rôles
précis d'abord conseiller le
gouvernement pour la préparation des
projets de loi ou décret mais il est
surtout le juge suprême administrative
qui tranche les litiges relatifs aux
actes et des administrations
l'extension du pass sanitaires ont fait
partie l'institution elle doit à se
prononcer sur sa légalité
déjà contesté il ya un mois par une
association de la défense des libertés
estimant que le dispositif divulgue de
façon injustifiée à des données
personnelles
le recours a été rejeté le 6 juillet
dernier
le compte rendu du mouvement est plutôt
clair le juge des référés relève que ce
dispositif papier au numérique n'est pas
requis pour les activités du quotidien
ou l'exercice de certaines libertés
fondamentales manifestations réunions
exercice du culte
le juge des référés estime que le passé
militaire ne porte pas une atteinte
grave et illégale au droit au respect de
la vie privée ou au droit de la
protection des données personnelles
les activités du quotidien les mots sont
importants ont fait des débuts du mois
d'août si nous voulons entrer dans un
centre commercial par exemple il sera
obligatoire pour nous de présenter un
pass à sanitaires et cette action
pourrait être considéré comme un
pré-requis à une activité du quotidien
et donc se heurter un obstacle juridique
du côté des juristes les avis sont
plutôt partagés
le pass annie terre répond à un motif
d'intérêt public pour la préservation de
la santé de la population
la question sera de savoir si cette
extension du passani terre ne porte pas
une atteinte disproportionnée au droit
au respect de la vie privée ou à la
liberté d'aller et venir
un vigile pourra-t-il demander à une
personne si elle est vaccinée à l'entrée
d'un centre commercial
le débat n'est pas tranché une question
qui se pose également pour les
restaurateurs sont ils en droit de
demander l'identité de leurs clients
le constat est là les réponses sont pour
l'instant flou nos syndicats ont pas été
mis dans la boucle puisque on a été au
courant de rien donc de nouvelles
surprises
et puis encore à nous de faire des
contrôles on n'est pas là pour ça on est
pas des agents de l'état on n'est pas là
des contrôleurs on n'est pas là pour
mettre la pression à nos clients
également pour la vaccination
obligatoire en revanche le conseil
d'état n'est pas en mesure de retourner
cette demande de l'exécutif tout d'abord
pour une question de jurisprudence la
protection de la santé publique et non
individuelle est un objectif
inscrite dans la constitution en 2015 un
couple refusé de vacciner leurs deux
enfants contre trois maladies la
diphtérie le tétanos et la poliomyélite
alors que le code de la santé publique
les y oblige
raison invoquée ces trois maladies ont
quasiment disparu en france et les
risques semblait trop peu important pour
la santé de leurs enfants
pourtant les sages ont retoqué cette
demande car je cite en imposant ses
obligations de vaccination le
législateur a entendu lutter contre 3
maladie très grave et contagieuse ou
insusceptible d'être éradiquée malgré ça
tout reste possible pour le pass
sanitaires on se souvient lors de la loi
sécurité globale que les sages avaient
donné raison à la contestation populaire
reste à savoir sous quelle forme le
texte final arrivera en conseil des
ministres le 19 juillet prochain il
passera ensuite par l'assemblée
nationale le 21 juillet puis par le
sénat
la fameuse navette un parlementaire
avant d'être promulgué mais une question
demeure le pass annie père est il
incompatible avec les libertés
citoyennes
seul le conseil constitutionnel peut
répondre à cette question
s'il est saisi